even Colbert is one of several
late-night hosts Whose shows could go
dark tonight as more than 11 000
Hollywood Riders prepare to stop working
today and start picketing at the
Forefront of the strike says the union
are dwindling earnings for writers in
the age of streaming while companies
like Amazon Disney Netflix and our
parent company Paramount have flourished
the writers in a nutshell feel that the
streaming revolution has really left
them behind they don't get as much money
when shows play on streaming services
than they did when shows are played on
traditional linear television roughly 85
percent of households are subscribed to
at least one streaming service but the
writers claim they aren't sharing in
that success and with shows producing
fewer episodes each season writers
receive less pay the wga says almost
half of its TV writers work at the
minimum salary up from 33 percent from a
decade ago